[Musik]
75 jahre kriegsende gedenken an die
befreiung europas durch die alliierten
und an viele millionen opfer der
nazi-diktatur
wer hat das sagen bei europas finanzen
der europäische gerichtshof pocht nach
dem urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts
zur ezb darauf er sei allein zuständig
und die grenzen bleiben zu trotz
scharfer kritik will innenminister
seehofer noch mindestens eine woche
bei den grenzkontrollen bleiben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend in allen
an diesem 8
es ist der tag an dem die welt 75 jahre
zurückblickt als der zweite weltkrieg in
europa endlich vorbei ist das ist der
tag der befreiung deutschlands vom
nationalsozialismus
damals waren die deutschen tatsächlich
allein sorgt heute der bundespräsident
und weiter heute müssen wir allein
gedenken aber wir sind nicht allein die
korona pandemie hat die eigentlich
geplanten gedenkfeier unmöglich gemacht
wir beginnen heute abend mit einem
rückblick auf eine welt vor 75 jahren
die am boden liegt die exakte zahl der
toten in diesem krieg ist nur zu
schätzen bis zu 65 millionen menschen
die meisten davon zivilisten
fast jedes zweite opfer kommt aus der
damaligen sowjetunion viele gestorben in
einem vernichtungskrieg im osten den
hitler entfesselt hatte dazu kommt der
völkermord der nazis an sechs millionen
juden leid und zerstörung in nie
gekanntem ausmaß am ende eine einzige
trümmerlandschaft auch in deutschland
über 6,3 millionen tote über 20
millionen menschen haben ihre heimat
verloren
heute ein dreivierteljahrhundert später
sind aus feinden von einst freunde
geworden
die gräuel des krieges bleiben als
mahnung der bundespräsident sagt bei der
schlichten gedenkveranstaltung in berlin
es gibt keine erlösung von unserer
geschichte patricia wiedemeier berichtet
in berlin zwölf mal erklang die glocke
zum gedenken an das kriegsende an der
neuen wache mitten in der hauptstadt
legen die spitzen des staates grenze ab
der bundespräsident erinnerte an die
dauerhafte historische verantwortung der
deutschen
es gibt kein ende des erinnern
es gibt keine erlösung von unserer
geschichte denn ohne erinnerung
verlieren wir unsere zukunft
erinnern müsse man sich immer wieder an
das was am ersten september 1939 begann
der zweite weltkrieg mit dem überfall
auf polen stürzte deutschland die welt
in einen grausamen krieg der fast sechs
jahre andauerte und millionen opfer
forderte am 17 mai 1945 wurde die
bedingungslose kapitulation der
deutschen wehrmacht unterschrieben am 8
mai trat sie in kraft die alliierten
hatten nazi deutschland besiegt vor
allem die damalige sowjetunion brachte
dafür zahlreiche opfer
das ist ein heiliges datum für uns der
krieg hat praktisch jede familie
betroffen
wir haben für diesen sieg über den
nazismus 27 millionen menschen als
preisgegeben
der achter ist aber auch ein tag der
befreiung wie der frühere
bundespräsident von weizsäcker ist
formulierte steinmeier knüpft genau da
an
damals wurden wir befreit heute müssen
wir uns selbst befreien befreien von
hass und hetze von fremdenfeindlichkeit
und demokratie verachtung denn sie sind
doch nichts anderes als die alten bösen
geister in neuem gewand
es war ein ungewöhnliches gedenken heute
im dom von berlin hatten die kirchen in
einem ökumenischen gottesdienst vor
leeren bänken zu frieden aufgerufen
und ebenso wie der bundespräsident
mahnte sie die lehren zu ziehen aus der
vergangenheit die schuld bleibe man
könne dieses land nur mit gebrochenem
herzen lieben betonte steinmeier zum
abschluss eines sehr einsamen gedenkens
heute in berlin
gedenken nicht nur in berlin in moskau
feiern sie morgen offiziell den sieg der
sowjetunion russlands präsident wladimir
putin hat heute mit bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel telefoniert danach sagten
beide
die erinnerung an den schrecken des
krieges müsse wachgehalten werden
und das sind bilder aus washington wo
als präsident donald trump in der
weltkriegs gedenkstätte der getöteten us
soldaten gedachte bereits gestern hatte
der britische premierminister boris
johnson eine kerze entzündet am grab des
unbekannten soldaten in westminster
abbey
als hitler deutschland kapitulierte
feierten in frankreich tausende auf den
straßen
heute gedenken sie in paris und sie
schauen auch zurück auf das was sich in
den letzten jahrzehnten zwischen
deutschen und franzosen entwickelt hat
beziehungen politische wirtschaftliche
persönliche romantische über den
gedenktag in paris christel haus hände
desinfizieren ist pflicht auch für den
präsidenten auch bei einer historischen
feierstunde
diese zeremonie ist anders als alle
vorherigen wegen coroner müssen die
zuschauer wegbleiben präsident makro in
kleinster runde am grab des unbekannten
soldaten entfacht er die flamme
symbolisch neu gedenken an das
kriegsende meine großmutter wurde damals
aus deutscher gefangenschaft befreit
man musste erinnerung erhalten darüber
nachdenken und reden
vor genau 75 jahren strömten plötzlich
tausende auf die strassen von paris und
feierten
der krieg war vorbei
auf diese nachricht haben alle lange
gewartet aber erst am nachmittag des 8
mai um 15 uhr verkündeten lautsprecher
auf den champs élysées die kapitulation
der deutschen
es herrscht zwar frieden aber der hass
auf die kollaborateure kennt kaum
grenzen
frauen werden die köpfe geschoren und
hakenkreuz auf die stirn gemalt
doch diese zeiten sind vergangenheit der
feind wurde zum partner
deutschland und frankreich sind für mich
der kern europas der motor jeder der
beiden hat einen individuellen charakter
aber das ist normal
die mag series erklingt heute nicht nur
im gedenken an das kriegsende sondern
auch für den frieden und europa
deutschland liegt an diesem 8 mai 1945
am boden zum beispiel köln zu 70 prozent
in schutt und asche
hamburg etwa zur hälfte millionen
wohnungen sind zerstört oder beschädigt
die menschen hausen in trümmern kellern
und baracken und schaffen es kaum das
tägliche leben zu meistern wie sie das
kriegsende erlebt haben können immer
weniger aus eigener erfahrung berichten
auch deshalb gibt es heute digitale
projekte um diese zeit weiter erlebbar
zu machen
henriette de maizière lutz rakova zwölf
als er den einmarsch der roten armee in
berlin erlebte am elternhaus vor beirat
an die panzer richtung mitte zum
reichstag wollten hitler kaputt ihr
schlachtruf schon früher reden rackow
und sein vater über ihre eigene schuld
und verantwortung
ich glaube unsere familie die werden
volle distanz zu dem fazit verhältnissen
uns positioniert hatten trotzdem uns der
mit belastung nicht entziehen können und
da habe ich ihn nur dass papa will
erinnern 75 jahre später in zeiten der
korona krise was openair konzipiert war
es nun unter 75 jahre kriegsende punkt
berlin
eine virtuelle ausstellung bilder
geschichten und animationen eine
digitale zeitreise
sie zeigt brüche und kontinuitäten der
nachkriegszeit und aktuelle bezüge zur
heute zu einer ausstellung hat man die
möglichkeit in die geschichte
einzutauchen und natürlich noch einmal
warm bilder wie schockbilder auf den
zigarettenschachteln zu präsentieren
sagen dahin führt das moment hier gerade
gezündelt wird rechte tendenzen die
angst davor treibt auch viele der
besucher im sowjetischen ehrenmal in
berlin-treptow heute an das erstarkende
richten macht mir große sorgen und
vielleicht kann man den tag doch als
regelmäßigen feiertag etabliert nie
wieder krieg 75 jahre frieden natürlich
auch tag der kapitulation
aber wer als nachgeborene da bin ich
schon dafür dass wir das der achte mai
der tag der befreiung ein tag der an
schuld und verantwortung erinnert im
gestern und heute 75 jahre danach finden
sie auch umfassende informationen in der
zdf- heute- app unter anderem mit einem
interaktiven zeitstrahl zu den letzten
kriegstagen bis zum 8 mai 1945 so viel
zu diesem thema drei tage ist das
aufsehenerregende urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts alt jetzt hat
der europäische gerichtshof klar gemacht
dass er sich allein zuständig sieht wenn
es um die frage geht ob europäische
institutionen gegen eu recht verstoßen
die karlsruher richter hatten sich gegen
die europäischen kollegen gestellt als
sie die billionenschweren aufkäufe von
staatsanleihen der euro-länder durch die
europäische zentralbank als teilweise
verfassungswidrig einstufte
europas oberste richter konnten jetzt
die deutsche entscheidung könnte das
justizsystem der eu gefährden
dazu hören wir unsere korrespondentin
bei der eu anne gellinek einer guten
abend da stehen jetzt also zwei gerichte
quasi gegen einen
anders kann das der eu gefallen nein
diese rivalität zwischen einem deutschen
und einem europäischen gericht kann
zumindest der eu kommission hier in
brüssel überhaupt nicht gefallen denn
sie untergräbt die autorität des
höchsten europäischen gerichts
die eu-kommission hat erhebliche
bedenken zu dem richterspruch aus
karlsruhe und das weniger aus
inhaltlichen gründen denn schließlich
bleiben die staatsanleihen-ankäufe
erlaubt sie müssen nur besser begründet
werden als vielmehr wegen eines formalen
gründen die tatsache dass sich auch das
höchste ein nationales gericht gegen den
europäischen gerichtshof stellt wird
hier als gigantischer kollateralschaden
bewertet als einladung an länder wie
ungarn und polen sich künftig
richtersprüche aus vom ogh zu
widersetzen
und das sei sozusagen mit dem hinweis
dann versehen das ja auch der deutsche
musterschüler sich nicht an urteile des
bgh halte die eu kommission wird das
urteil nun prüfen und es gilt als sehr
wahrscheinlich dass sie es dass sie das
urteil so nicht stehen lassen wird und
dagegen vorgehen wird sie könnte ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren einleiten
das würde dann in letzter konsequenz
bedeuten dass die eu kommission
deutschland vor demselben europäischen
gerichtshof verklagen könnte die
hintergründe aus brüssel an herzlichen
dank dafür
und jetzt in der sendung der kampf gegen
das virus das da gucken wir zuerst auf
die aktuellen zahlen laut johns hopkins
universität wurde in deutschland bei
mehr als 169 1000 personen eine
infektion bestätigt knapp 142.000 davon
gelten mittlerweile als genesen 7392
menschen sind in verbindung mit dem
virus gestorben neue einschränkungen
wird es geben wenn eine obergrenze
erreicht ist und die liegt bei 50
neuinfektionen gemessen auf 100.000
einwohner innerhalb der letzten sieben
tage nach dem landkreis greiz über den
wir gestern berichtet haben wird diese
marke jetzt auch in den kreisen
steinburg und coesfeld überschritten
in beiden fällen hat sich das virus
unter mitarbeitern von schlachtbetrieben
verbreitet aus nordrhein westfalen
berichtet alexander
westfleisch mitarbeiter im
münsterländischen coesfeld viele von
ihnen haben sich mit corona angesteckt
die fleischprodukte könnten kunden
unbedenklich essen sagen die behörden
der betrieb aber hat nun ein problem die
entscheidung der behörden dass sie den
schlachtrufen in coesfeld schließen
werden und dass alle mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter dieses schlachthofes
selbstverständlich getestet werden 151
infizierte bei 3 100 getesteten
mitarbeitern 900 test stehen noch aus
die behörden werden verstöße gegen
abstandsregeln im zerlegebetrieb
probleme auch in der unterbringung der
osteuropäischen vertragsarbeiter
subunternehmer schicken sie in
gemeinschaftsunterkünften abstands und
hygiene regeln kontrolliert dort niemand
zu den infizierten mitarbeitern teilt
westfleisch mit sie befinden sich ebenso
wie ihre kontaktpersonen in häuslicher
quarantäne
die nrw behörden wollen nun
sammelunterkünfte für ausländische
vertragsarbeiter kontrollieren müssen
aber betroffenen landkreise komplett
stillgelegt werden lockerungen
verschoben da wo es einrichtungs bezogen
nachvollziehbar ist soll es einrichtungs
bezogen maßnahmen geben und da wo es
nicht mehr nachvollziehbar es muss lokal
und regional maßnahmen geben in coesfeld
ist der infektionsherd bekannt trotzdem
verschieben die behörden die
angekündigten lockerungen nun für den
gesamten landkreis um eine woche hier
zahlen alle bürger den preis für die
hausgemachten probleme der
fleischindustrie gucken noch für im
moment ein bisschen genereller darauf
thomas münten ist für uns live in
coesfeld nahm thomas corona ausbruch im
schlachtbetrieb ist das jetzt ein
einzelfall oder gibt es dann probleme in
der branche generell es gibt ein problem
in der branche generell und das bezieht
sich nicht nur auf coesfeld das bezieht
sich nicht nur auf deutschland sondern
quasi auf ganz westeuropa
und es betrifft auch nicht nur fleisch
betriebe natürlich auch die
spargelbauern auch das was an erdbeeren
geerntet wird das sind alles
leiharbeiter aus osteuropa die unter
teilweise ja man muss schon sagen
manchmal unwürdigen umständen hier in
deutschland leben und arbeiten aber die
das natürlich tun weil sie da immer noch
besser verdienen als wenn sie zu hause
blieb
das ganze wie gesagt führt jetzt hier
erstmal dazu dass die menschen in
coesfeld relativ ärgerlich sind weil die
für montag angekündigte öffnung von
geschäften und restaurants jetzt um
mindestens eine woche verschoben wird
und wie das hier weitergeht das muss man
abwarten denn dazu fehlen ja zumindest
hier allein noch 900 tests auf jeden
fall thomas mit herzlichen dank für
diese information heute abend live aus
coesfeld ja eine weitere woche mit
vielen entwicklungen in sachen virus
geht zu ende gucken wir darauf was die
deutschen dazu sagen matthias fornoff
hat ein ganz neues politbarometer
arbeitsamen matthias wie ist denn die
meinung der menschen zu diesen
lockerungen die jetzt für abgekommen wir
sehen da an ziemlich differenziertes
bild denn immerhin 38 prozent sagen es
ist noch zu früh für lockerungen 47
prozent finden die kommen gerade richtig
und elf prozent hätten sie gerne schon
früher gehabt wenn man die letzten
beiden addiert also gerade richtig und
besser früher
dann ist eine mehrheit von 58 prozent im
grundsatz für lockerungen dass wieder
mehr kontakte möglich sind finden gut
zwei drittel der deutschen richtig und
weitere 15 prozent hätten das gerne
schon früher gehabt diese einschränkung
tat also offenbar am meisten weh
interessant wieder nach unterscheidung
gemacht und dann die frage wie schlägt
sich das alles jetzt nieder auf die
handelnden in der politik naja das
unterschiedliche regeln gelten dass in
den unterschiedlichen ländern das
polarisiert auf jeden fall eine knappe
mehrheit findet das richtig 45 prozent
aber finden das nicht richtig hätten
sich bundesweite regeln gewünscht
grundsätzlich aber kommt das
krisenmanagement der bundesregierung gut
an
das sehen wir hier 81 prozent sagen die
regierung macht ihre sache in der korona
krise gut bei einem thema allerdings
sieht es ganz anders aus den
wiederanpfiff der fußball-bundesliga
ohne zuschauer findet nur knapp jeder
dritte gut eine mehrheit hätte den
abbruch der saison besser gefunden
politbarometer mit matthias fornoff
danke sehr gern
wir bleiben auch im moment beim thema
corona verändert unseren alltag noch mal
ganz besonders in den regionen in denen
es eigentlich kaum noch echte
grenzen gab bis mitte mai soll es jetzt
aber weiter grenzkontrollen geben
mindestens viele menschen wünschen sich
dass die zeit der abgeriegelten grenzen
ein ende hat anna warsberg und simon
pfanzelt waren ganz im süden an der
deutsch schweizerischen grenze seit 16
jahren sind edelsteine und uwe brei ein
paar die schweizerin er deutscher dass
sie nun seit wochen ein bauzaun trend
hier an der grenze bei konstanz regt die
beiden auf mittlerweile nervt
mittlerweile fühlt der bodensee
eigentlich ein symbol für das
zusammengewachsene europa hier treffen
deutschland österreich und die schweiz
aufeinander
doch im märz war schluss mit den offenen
grenzen jetzt endlich wieder öffnen
wünschen sich viele politiker in der
region was ich fordere ich darf man im
nachgang guckt was rausgekommen ist und
jetzt ist die situation in deutschland
und in der schweiz die gleiche von den
infektionszahlen und dann gibt es keinen
grund mehr für die grenze zuletzt hatte
bundesinnenminister seehofer die
grenzkontrollen verteidigt und bis 15
mai verlängert die grenzkontrollen haben
etwas bewirkt uns sind teil unseres
bisherigen erfolgs bei der eindämmung
desinfektions geschehens doch in
konstanz wachsen die zweifel auch aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen
michael hepp ist optiker rund ein
drittel seiner kunden sind schweizer und
die dürfen jetzt nicht mehr kommen ja
kein deutsches hinterland dort trennt
uns der zeh vom restlichen deutschland
deswegen haben wir weniger frequenz in
der stadt ich hoffe dass wirklich diese
zone fallen
dass die nicht mehr die staaten an sich
denken sondern dass wir europäisch
denken und da wird die schweiz dazu es
ist getrennt was über jahrzehnte
zusammen gewachsen ist
diesen zustand zu überwinden darauf
hoffen jetzt viele die grenzen bleiben
ein streitthema entschieden sind schon
lockerungen für die wirtschaft geschäfte
und restaurants eröffnen mehr kontakte
sind möglich doch viele eltern von
kleinkindern warten noch vergeblich auf
offene kitas einige bundesländer
darunter nordrhein westfalen bieten
demnächst zumindest für vorschulkinder
eine betreuung an
noch einen schritt weiter geht's sachsen
hier öffnen die kitas am 18 mai wieder
für alle kinder
und dann kommen wir zum thema sport im
freien da bewegt sich da wird es ja
jetzt bald doch wieder bewegung geben da
ist immer mehr möglich die frage ist
aber was ist mit sport drinnen in
fitnessstudios haben bundesweit über elf
millionen menschen trainiert bevor sie
geschlossen wurden meist auf engem raum
nordrhein westfalen will jetzt ab montag
die hanteln und laufbänder freigeben
unter auflagen peter böhme berichtet
abstand durch absperrband in bottrop
legen sie geräte still
das schafft distanz wenn die sportler
trainieren wiedereröffnung nächste woche
rollt vorbei kathrin tomczak und ihren
mitarbeitern ja wahnsinnig also acht
wochen schließung wehrte sich das
gedacht dass wir so was mal fahren
müssen und insofern freuen wir uns
absolut und total auf den tag
es wird ein neuanfang mit
einschränkungen die jedes bundesland
selbst erlässt der deutsche sportstudio
verband empfiehlt zum beispiel
trainingsgeräte nach jeder nutzung zu
desinfizieren pro studio je nach größe
nur eine bestimmte anzahl kunden
trainieren zu lassen und sauna und
massage bereiche vorerst geschlossen zu
lassen
umziehen und duschen auch das in bottrop
nur daheim und war nun weniger geräte
bereit stehen müssen sich viele kunden
ihre trainingszeit in zukunft
reservieren
die devise viel weniger menschen
gleichzeitig im fitnesscenter als früher
wie vorher wird wahrscheinlich kaum
irgendwo etwas werden und es sind große
anstrengungen die die anlagen
unternehmen mussten und wir werden mit
sicherheit zwei jahre brauchen um
bestimmte dinge wieder aufzuholen
das ist nun bald losgeht viele menschen
volz
ich habe schon vermisst ich wäre gern
gegangen weil ich mich zu hause einfach
nicht so sehr motivieren kann wie im
fitnessstudio ja erstmal den sport
sowieso und auch das soziale umfeld man
hat ja auch mittlerweile viele bekannte
weil es war der ablauf immer so sport
hinterher schönen gang gegner sauna auf
die sauna muss er noch verzichten aber
sport immerhin kann er wieder machen
und jetzt haben wir für sie zum schluss
noch ein tolles naturschauspiel dass wir
in der nacht beobachten konnten
der super mond in all seiner pracht
weltweit zu sehen london istanbul und
zwischen den wolkenkratzern von singapur
sehr hell und sehr groß einen super mond
gibt es immer dann wenn der vollmond der
erde auf seiner umlaufbahn besonders nah
kommt das ist der romantische
nachthimmel in venezuela und das waren
die 19 uhr nachrichten das wetter es
bleibt erst mal für die meisten sonnig
und warm nur im süden gibt es einige
schauer genauer aussichten gleich von
gunther tiersch der kollege claus kleber
freut sich auf sie um 22 uhr und morgen
an dieser stelle ist petra gerster für
sie da vom gesamten team danke für ihr
großes interesse ich wünsche ihnen ein
sehr angenehmer
[Musik]
einige zuschauer es wird jetzt
unbeständig bei uns denn die warme luft
aus dem südwesten wird zunehmend
feuchter und deshalb entstehen in den
nächsten 24 stunden über süddeutschland
immer mal wieder schauer und gewitter
währenddessen formiert sich hier diese
wetterfront mit regen mit schnee über
der nordsee und sie kommt dann am
sonntag erreicht am nachmittag schon
hamburg und dann in der nächsten woche
eben auch ganz deutschland heute nacht
gibt es ein paar schauer wahrscheinlich
hier westlich des rheins aber auch mal
gewitter südlich der donau und am
kühlsten wird es an der elbe etwa mit
drei bis fünf grad könnte auch
bodenfrost mit dabei sein
deutlich milder ist es im südwesten bis
14 grad und tagsüber es wird sommerlich
wie heute auch 21 bis 27 grad auch an
der see sind es 17 bis 19 grad und es
wird sonnig in norddeutschland mit der
tendenz dass es nachmittags fleischmann
schauern mecklenburg vorpommern gibt
ansonsten bleibt es trocken und erst in
süddeutschland ist die bewölkung stärker
es wird immer wieder schauer geben die
durchziehen vereinzelt kann es auch mal
ein gewitter geben und immer wieder
zwischendurch kommt auch die sonne aus
dem südwesten raus ja der sonntag bringt
schauer und gewitter in deutschland die
kühle luft macht sich an der nordsee
bemerkbar und die rutscht uns dann am
montag und am dienstag bis zu den alpen
zum teil mit regen und auch mit schnee
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut